[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans envies de
lecture avec nathalie wolf bonjour bon
ami merci beaucoup matrice bonjour et
bonne année également alors va recevoir
quelqu'un de formidable qui s'appelle
pantxo qui top dessinateur qui est un
peintre qui est un caricaturiste
nous présentons me dit bonjour déjà re
bonjour pantxo bonjourbonjour bel et
bien on me font dire bonjour vous n'êtes
pas un autre comme vient de le dire
patrice dessinateurs caricaturistes de
nombreuses collaborations
alors chaque semaine évidemment au
canard enchaîné pendant plus de 20 ans
au monde
vous dessinez également pour le magazine
littéraire au new review of books et
puis il encore beaucoup d'autres
les expositions également on peut citer
celle qui s'est tenue en septembre
dernier à madrid
on efface tout et on recommence selon la
traduction française
une allusion indirecte également la
crise de l'aco vide alors compte sur
vous êtes né au venezuela caracas
et puis vous avez vécu en uruguay à
montevideo avant de fuir la dictature
est d'arriver ici en france les arts la
liberté d'expression la démocratie la
dictature
voilà tous les thèmes que nous allons
aborder avec vous merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous alors on va commencer par le
dernier livre que vous avez illustré qui
s'appelle invisible visite et paris chez
baker street grandes maisons d'édition
c'est le il ya trois trois auteurs que
vous illustrez il ya rainbow il ya guy
de maupassant et henry james avait que
des textes assez connus poussé l'homme
son souffle c'est un homme qui mérite à
lise sa famille lui qui va perdre son
souffle et comment va-t-il le retrouve
va-t-il de retrouver le horla de
maupassant qui relate évidemment les
terreurs d'un homme qui croit déceler
une présence à ses côtés et puis le tour
d'écrou nom réel c'est aussi une
nouvelle extrêmement connue est ce que
c'est cette littérature qui est une
littérature fantastique est une
littérature dont vous êtes familier oui
j'ai laine j'allais beaucoup ce type de
littérature mais
j'étais enfin une pétition et les
comptes l'histoire de maupassant c'est
pas moi qui vais le stress et l
illustrateur de waly ndiaye et les
autres ben oui james et des jeux j'aime
beaucoup ce type d'histoire alors pour
ces évolué mais vous avez pas de show
spécialement créé les illustrations de
ces textes on aimerait savoir comment
vous avez travaillé
est ce qu'il ya une difficulté
particulière à illustrer des récits
fantastiques tu as quand même le dessin
doit suggérer mais pas trop montrer oui
ma première difficulté c'est que je suis
dessinateur je suis et j'aime est sympa
compliments illustrateur je préfère des
situations je les fréquente le monde est
là aux médias commander c'est un défi je
les faits et alors c'est ça va aider les
faits justement de ne pas l'être à
pouvoir trouver des techniques
différentes pour traiter chaque sujet
ce que je voudrais faire et dans ces cas
là oui et j'essaie de ne pas être trop
explicite au littéraire val la façon de
dessiner des sujets plutôt que de dieu
alors justement on va parler un peu de
ce métier de dessinateur de presse mais
bon c'est un métier qui on a
l'impression que ça malheureusement est
un peu en voie de disparition il ya plus
beaucoup d'autres fois il est des
dessins en une de tous les journaux
aujourd'hui vous êtes au canard enchaîné
notamment car encore heureusement des
dessinateurs de presse
mais c'est vrai que c'est un métier
qu'on qui est presque tendance à
disparaître
oui j'ai bien peur je ne sais pas qu'est
ce qui va arriver je ne sais pas dans
cinq ans qu'est ce qui va arriver que ce
type des choses et j'espère que qui
savoir pouvoir continuer le problème
c'est qu'avec les réseaux sociaux il ya
une autre façon de travailler et c'est
devenu beaucoup plus compliqué et il ya
beaucoup de gens qui peuvent s'exprimer
sans cesse des professionnels tous les
réseaux sociaux ça complique les choses
et parce que l'instigateur des prises
normal c'est lui qui est là car c'est
tout ça une certaine responsabilité
travail dans un journal il doit
affronter des poursuites judiciaires
parfois et il doit faire attention c'est
qu'il fait les gens qui sont sur les
réseaux sociaux ne le font pas alors on
prêt mais là j'ai tout ça et on ne sait
plus où se trouve là vous venez nadal
ils le disent et hydra venait d'amérique
du sud est ce que vous vous nous
raconter en quelques mots votre parcours
comment vous êtes arrivé en france
pourquoi d'accord non je suis quand j'ai
commencé à leur goût et la fin des
années 60 l'année 68
mon premier dessin publié
professionnellement c'est un portrait de
l'auteur king tous les jours après son
assassinat et c'était dans une
publication qui s'appelait marc chayer
resté mythique l'exclu qui est avec la
place du monde dans la société
orwellienne et c'était un hebdomadaire
ce n'est pas un quotidien alors et g
j'ai commencé là et puis la chance de
connaître des directeurs les fondateurs
qui c'était quelqu'un qui m'a fort matin
quelque part c'était d'avocats qui avait
fait des études d'économie en france
dans les années 20 qui était très
francophile j'ai vu les deux premiers du
monde pour celle de secteur l'action et
la fin de l'année 59 il m'a confié la
page douloureuse de la dernière page du
journal et on a travaillé ensemble
jusqu'en l'année les fin de l'année 73
quand les coups de tête et déjà est
installé en bout et ont fermé toutes les
publications alors je suis parti avec ma
famille d'abord en argentine pendant
deux ans et je travaille dans la presse
aussi j'avais commencé mais en argentine
il avait une autre coup d'état
l'approché est allé beaucoup plus dur
l'an dernier 76 et comme j'étais né au
venezuela j'avais les papiers je pouvais
partir je les fais mon père avait été là
bas et la famille de mon père alors
revenez cela j'ai travaillé pendant 8
ans dans ce journal un des principaux
journaux de cela et le national et comme
il avait un très bon dessinateur sapata
kifissia la caricature quotidienne
ciot nalbandian moi je me suis
spécialisé dans la politique
internationale parce que je connaissais
pas le contexte de la politique et après
quelques années c'était venu
j'étais très bien aussi d'allemand mais
et c'est comme si je pourrai plus me
développer alors j'ai pensé à je
fantasmais reculer d'entrer dans les
marchés internationaux alors des
possibilités si tu es allé à new york en
devenir à paris new york c'était très
violent à l'époque fin des années
soixante dix alors avec ma famille de
l'époque on a décidé de venir à paris
j'ai eu la chance de pouvoir venir et
j'ai commencé à céder l'année 83 j'ai
commencé assez vite à collaborer avec
les bombes mais des façons quotidien
c'est l année 86,6 d'accord
enfin c'est pas été trop trop compliqué
de trouver du boulot à paris comme ça
que vous êtes arrivé et ce oui ça a été
compliqué les permise année j'ai
collaboré dans un tas de publications
périphériques et tout ça avec les mondes
aussi avec magazine littéraire avec
magazine dire avec une très grande
deltheillerie stick à l'époque de la
radio c'était jean-pierre clic et qui
nous a ouvert des portes aussi et oui et
jusqu'au moment où le monde a c'était
avait chargé un tout petit peu c'était
très forte du nouveau directeur il avait
placé plantu à la ligne du journal a ri
et m'a contacté pour remplacer plantu
comme ils partaient en vacances et faire
justement fonctions le dessin de presse
renvoie généralement la satire à
l'actualité
et quand on a préparé l'émission et
patrice ou retourner mais comment est ce
qu'on fait impertinent drôle 365 jours
sur 365
donc comment vous comment vous
travaillez est ce que vous répondez sur
toi des commandes vous fait des dessins
de prendre l'initiative
c'est pas toujours facile guère
différent façon de travailler bloc
simple et pour le monde
j'ai fait 16 de 51 et c'était avec des
sujets clés journal mais proposé est
alors j'ai fait c'est parfois une idée
parfois plusieurs et j'ai négocié avec
les rédacteurs en chef à voir quelle
était la meilleure
s'il n'y avait pas les problèmes avec un
travail tellement vite c'est que parfois
on véhicule une idée que ne s'était pas
c'est bien d'avoir les regarder
quelqu'un d'autre au canard enchaîné
c'est différent on propose aux hommes
une douzaine de dessinateurs
on peut pas tous une certaine quantité
de dessin et la direction choisie s'en
rendre compte on sait pas pourquoi les
scènes quelques-uns sont réfugiés par
d'autres il y un centaine de dessins
parfois qui sont proposés il est 35 sont
évités il ya toujours d'accord avec les
soit ou pas vous êtes toujours d'accord
avec les choix de la rédaction ou pas
n'ont pas toujours pas toujours mais
c'est comme ça et le journal que plus il
ya une grande tradition de travailler
comme ça ils vont pas chercher alors on
s'habitue aux sous les yeux ressemble
évidemment bon allez le métier de
dessinateur de presse de caricaturistes
vous parliez des réseaux sociaux ce qui
change en effet des choses mais il ya
aussi surtout les les attentats de de
charlie est ce que ça a changé votre
façon de dessiner ce que ça change et
votre métier ou autres responsabilités
et certaines choses qui se sont passées
des dernières années et on a changé
notre façon de travailler je crois parce
que c'est pas seulement des attentats et
charlie c'est aussi par exemple les néo
féminisme c'est l'anti racisme c'est à
dire si j'ai vu je vais faire un dessin
où il y a
par exemple quelqu'un qui peut que les
vaccins ce moment et face à une personne
qui était un complotiste et je suivais
côté de celui qui est pour les basses
entre les tribus je me ferai vacciner
alors et si dans les places des
complotistes j'aimais et une femme j'ai
peut-être accéder en effet ministe
nation si je l'aimé il femmes voilées je
peux et accéder
déçu de la mort si j'émets un black jeu
peut taxer de racisme il faut faire
attention à qui n'est pas justement des
frictions à partir d'une idée est vrai
très simple il y une dizaine d'années on
ne se posait pas se dédouble et ça
complique les ça complique le métier ça
complique le métier te pour wii est ce
qu'on peut revoir le descend que trop
chier dutreuil inédit dessins inédits et
puis vous avez fait de façon
prémonitoire parce que vous le faites le
matin du 6 janvier je ne crois bon on va
pas vous demander de commenter vos
dessins ils parlent d'eux mêmes et quand
même en dessous vous vous posez des
questions vous qui avaient fui la
dictature vous l'évoquiez en tout à
l'heure est-ce que vous pensez que nos
démocraties sont des bien fragile et
quelle est votre réaction
et bien quand vous entendez le mot
dictature par exemple en france employés
à peut-être à tort et à travers
oui je crois que malheureusement les
démocraties sont fragiles
il faut les protéger il faut les
perfectionner les magazines ne sont pas
parfaites il ya beaucoup de choses qui
ne marchent pas mais comme dit il c'est
le pire des systèmes à l'exception de
tous les autres et ils sont effectives
et je crois qu'il faut les protéger il
faut laisser regarder parce que c'est
une façon d et partagé les pôles
alternative sinon c'est la guerre civile
aux navigateurs et la dictature j'ai
vécu un peu ça je suis en uruguay
et quand j'entends parler des dictatures
pour ce qui se passe en france
actuellement
mais faire rigoler parce qu'elle est on
n'imagine pas qu'est ce que c'est que la
bible sur son ordinateur
merci infiniment pour ce show alors je
rappelle ce disque baker street
invisible visiteurs vous avez illustré
et puis et puis évidemment vous retrouve
tous les mercredis dans le cadre merci
d'avancé vous merci a bientot ces bugs
[Musique]